on est parti aujourd'hui à la rencontre
des agriculteurs qui faisaient grève et
qui était vraiment très en colère et
après ceux qui manifestent pour
travailler moins on est tombé sur celui
qui voulait travailler plus et bien on
est venu défendre l'agriculture parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous on vient demander à
pouvoir travailler c'est assez rare de
faire une manifestation pour demander à
travailler oui c'est vrai et on est
aussi tombé sur le mec qui a un peu trop
siphonné son tracteur il y a un
producteur
vous avez un transporteur vous avez une
sucrerie des entreprises de
transformation et on est aussi tombé sur
un mec qui n'avait rien à là
bonjour monsieur vous êtes agriculteur
mais pas trop et vous avez un message à
faire passer alors je dis coucou à mon
épouse Véronique bisous
à faire passer pour le gouvernement quoi
pour le on est tombé sur des
agriculteurs qui avaient des slogans
bien préparés et si vous avez aller on
est en
colère et d'autres un peu moins on s'en
bat les couilles
[Applaudissements]
dans cette manifestation on avait aussi
le Mozart du klaxon le mec installé un
klaxon de ouf sur son tracteur il est
ambiance et tout le monde dans la manif
regardez et enfin nos équipes ont
rencontré l'agriculteur le plus jodial
et vous allez voir il a des klaxons à
pas piqué des hannetons 25 mélodies sur
mon sur mon tracteur voilà plus connue
ça va être baby Shark je sais pas si
vous connaissez
[Musique]
et après baby Shark joyeux anniversaire
universel
et on traverse l'Atlantique avec Docteur
Dre
W et enfin on termine avec le
Jean-Jacques Goldman des prés et les
endives moi j'ai des vrais bien
françaises
on est aussi tombé sur un mec très
remonté contre le gouvernement seul
problème il avait pas répété de ouf les
slogans avant de venir à la manif
regardez
nos journalistes des agriculteurs en
altitude qu'est-ce que tu as à dire au
gouvernement que c'est toujours on nous
supprime tout un tas de choses on nous
enlève tous nos moyens de production
donc s'il y a plus besoin d'agriculteurs
en France il faut le dire on arrête tout
et voilà et vous allez voir que pour son
slogan et c'est pas trop fait chier
quand même bah aidez-nous quoi
il a raison on est tombé sur un
agriculteur qui s'appelle Jean-Guy et
visiblement lui il aimerait bien
partager un repas avec moi surtout c'est
pour ça j'ai fait la réforme des
retraites gueuler plus alors que là au
moins ça boite un petit coup le problème
il est attends Touche pas à mon poste
vous êtes de quoi vous
c'est 8 on connaît pas mais Hanouna
Hanouna
je voulais un petit sandwich
[Applaudissements]
on a retrouvé mon ami Jean-Guy qui était
bien occupé pendant 15 de ses collègues
était en train de nous parler regardez
ça très drôle regardez bien derrière
et on est toujours avec Jean-Guy qui a
décidé de joindre l'utile à l'agréable
pendant cette manifestation qui pensions
à ça on se dit
dans le métier vous comprenez nos
dirigeants c'est c'est hallucinant ils
font rien quoi on peut prendre des
mauvaises décisions à moi dans mon
entreprise je reprends mais je ne fais
pas que ça que prendre des mauvaises
décisions
quand même
merci on est bien reçu hein
on a toujours eu la main surtout ouais
il y a pas de CRS bizarrement c'est
magnifique nous on est là pour voir des
couilles s'amuser donc on dit ce qu'on
pense
à bientôt
leur fait des gros bisous
j'ai vraiment j'ai adoré ces glaces
franchement c'est voilà c'est tout ce
que j'aime Francky là on a voulu rigoler
un peu mais c'est vrai que la situation
est très grave vous vous êtes serré
allié alors la manifestation
chef de culture d'accord d'une
exploitation agricole j'ai des patrons
j'ai des comptes à rendre et bon je suis
dedans depuis 27 ans
moi je suis paysan c'est pareil
aujourd'hui combien
vous arrivez à dégager par mois alors
moi je suis un salarié moi j'ai mon
salaire en fait l'exploitation de 300
hectares de mes patrons si on veut elle
me fait vivement d'accord elle ne fait
pas vivre le patron qui sont âgés ils
ont des enfants les enfants n'ont pas
voulu reprendre l'exploitation
parce que ils ont fait des études ils
ont voulu faire autre chose parce que
aujourd'hui l'agriculture n'attire plus
aujourd'hui
moi je
suis venu parler pour la manif grosso
modo je suis en colère on est tous en
colère parce que on nous a donné une
décision il y a enfin janvier d'arrêter
les traitements de semences Nanny
cotténoïdes des betteraves bon très bien
c'est une langue européenne sauf que
depuis deux ans je Macron notre cher
Président nous a donné des dérogations
chaque année pour le refaire pour 3 ans
pour le temps de trouver des nouvelles
variétés des nouvelles génétiques des
nouvelles techniques malheureusement il
faudrait plus longtemps parce que une
année c'est qu'une année on fait qu'une
un essai par an et puis la veille de
nous donner l'autorisation bizarrement
l'Europe a dit non tout le monde a
arrêté donc vous vous arrêtez très bien
pas de problème monsieur Macron était
gentil il a dit ah les gars l'Europe a
dit stop sauf que en Europe prenez
l'Allemagne prenez la Belgique on est
certains pays ils n'ont pas de
traitement de semence mais ils ont des
insecticides très puissants qui mettent
en plein champ donc avec les tonneaux
vous imaginez donc pour le coup qui tue
les auxiliaires les abeilles la
biodiversité
et nous on ne les a pas nous parce que
nous en France on se l'interdit donc on
joue un match de foot mais pas avec les
mecs
nous on joue avec les pieds vous jouez
avec les pieds et les mains c'est ça
donc
à ce moment-là l'Union européenne c'est
pour tout le monde donc il y a un moment
c'est
j'ai envie de dire il sort un peu les
coronaises et puis il dit non mais il y
a certains pays en Europe ils l'ont dit
bon bah moi je préfère mais
planteurs pour l'instant on est aux
autorise c'est bien de le dire c'est
parce que ça c'est on sait pas si parce
que il faut savoir que le excusez-moi
rien que la filière betterave on vous
entendez au médium partout c'est 40 000
emplois c'est complètement faux c'est
bien plus que ça emploi direct indirect
transporteur enfin machiniste tout c'est
énorme ça représente entre 6 et 10
milliards de PIB le sucre en France
alors demain on va arrêter cette année
déjà rien qu'avec l'annonce 30% de
planteurs en moins on va se prendre une
gamelle si on en était un printemps secs
ce qu'on va se reprendre la maladie avec
le puceron donc on va faire 30 tonnes ou
40 tonnes donc pas rentable du tout on
va perdre du pognon l'année prochaine on
fera plus de betteraves qu'est-ce qui se
passera les sucreries fermeront donc une
économie qui s'arrêtera très bien pas de
souci éthanol vous savez comment c'est
fait éthanol en France c'est 100%
betterave française donc le 1 € ce sera
deux trois euros parce qu'on apportera
les betteraves parce que faut pas rêver
moi j'entends des écolos je suis pas
contre les écolos attention j'entends
des écolos qui me disent oui mais non
mais Francky c'est bien on mange en
moins de sucre ben moi le premier j'en
mange moins c'est sûr mais je suis qui
ne sert pas à manger cher pour voilà
exactement il y en a partout il y en a
partout et ben on voit l'importer du
Brésil on va l'apporter des pays de
l'Est avec des produits que on imaginez
même pas ce qu'ils mettent dedans et là
on dirait on a le cul propre on a un
pays propre ce qu'on a fait des bonnes
des bonnes solutions mais par contre on
bouffe de la merde alors Laurence coup
de gueule Laurent vous êtes éleveur vous
avez une ferme biologique en Normandie
et pour vous le quotidien d'éleveur
c'est de plus en plus compliqué vous
êtes éleveur depuis combien de temps je
me suis installé en 2001 donc ça fait
plus de 22 ans 22 ans vous êtes
installés au début ça se passait bien
pour vous oui j'avais comment dire je
suis installé dans une zone naturelle en
vallée de scène qui est une zone
sensible environnementale qui est en
Natura 2000 c'était à dire qu'il y a une
responsabilité au niveau de la
biodiversité donc en fait on vous
demande de vous investir en faisant
attention justement auxiliaires et en
préservant en fait l'environnement qui
est présent et en fait les choses se
compliquent de plus en plus et
comment dire la on n'a pas trop le droit
à l'erreur puisqu'en fait on est tous
dépendant d'aide pour nous exploitations
on doit avoir la santé on doit tirer
prochaine
construire une vie familiale c'est
compliqué puisqu'en fait on est beaucoup
pris
là je suis ici présent parce qu'en fait
mon ami Patrick Morin qui a créé la
marge de l'espoir
qui soutient les éleveurs en difficulté
en grave difficulté souhaité que je leur
présente puisque je suis un exemple de
quelqu'un qui
essaye qui a présente bien son combat et
en fait on fait de la concurrence on le
vouloir tout un tas de gens qui veulent
se réapproprier la nature et en même
temps on est des hommes on a nos
faiblesses on peut avoir des problèmes
de santé on n'a pas toujours de solution
pour ça non plus alors
vous avez décidé de faire ce métier
pourquoi vous
en fait à l'origine je suis diplômé dans
le sport spécialiste sport de combat et
choisis ce métier là parce que pour moi
protéger l'environnement faire
un pas entre la nature et l'agriculture
en liant les deux c'est qu'il y avait
une logique alors actuelle en fait il y
a plus de logique la logique avec que
financière quand vous achetez votre
morceau de viande ou votre salade vous
posez pas forcément de questions si le
champ est l'entourait de s si
la bête elle est elle est née en France
mais qu'elle a mangé en France qu'elle a
grandi en France
on nous regarde des fois comme des gens
forcément on je m'appelle Levacher
j'adore mes vaches c'est une passion
tant que le bœuf n'est pas mon cousin
comment dire on a beaucoup de mal à
trouver des difficultés puisque en fait
on est des concurrents à pas mal de gens
par rapport à l'espace en ce qui
concerne mon exemple
au niveau de la ferme un projet
immobilier c'est approcher et en fait
mais en concurrence et une tenue
dangereusement à l'évolution de
l'exploitation et en même temps on a
beaucoup de choses qui sont là pour nous
faire baisser les bras plutôt que de
nous aider à nous accompagner à franchir
tous ces combats alors c'est en plus des
problèmes de santé je crois bien sûr
covid on a perdu du covid comment ça se
passe quand on est éleveur quand on a
des problèmes de santé on fait quoi
quand on fait comment en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'était
en fait j'ai fait 9 tests covid ils ont
tous été négatifs et en fait dans
l'année 2020 je fais un test j'avais des
Kiss de 7 mm sur les poumons et en fait
j'ai fait mon travail comme je pouvais à
la vitesse que j'avais que je pouvais
donc j'avais 9 à 10 ans quand en fait on
n'a pas le temps de faire notre travail
en temps et en heure en entretien pas
bien forcément nos clôtures nos animaux
peuvent se sauver
la tolérance sur les routes vu que ça
peut générer des accidents c'est très
compliqué
on cherche pas forcément de tolérance
mais des compromis au moins et puis en
même temps en fait c'est on travaille
aussi pour vous parce qu'en fait on
donne notre vie pour vous
bon bien on doit acheter toute notre
capital en nous le donne pas on l'achète
bien on sait pas un jour à quel prix on
le revendra en fait quand vous êtes en
ville vous avez pas de jardin quand vous
arrivez en vacances dans nos campagnes
et ben en fait vous aimez les voir
Fleury avec des arbres avec des avec des
animaux sauvages c'est grâce aussi à ces
agriculteurs qui qui font la part des
choses et plus que jamais on a besoin de
vous pour soutenir
comment dire ce métier
les éleveurs qui pour beaucoup auraient
visent leur cheptel où sont découragé
parce qu'il y a trop d'heures de travail
le prix d'énergie qui a flambé autour de
ça et qui comment dire où en fait ça
nous laisse pas de perspective
c'est-à-dire qu'on sait c'est nouveau
pour nous c'est pas ce que ça va donner
et puis avec ça faut vivre faut qu'on
soit une famille si on a des enfants
faut c'est pas mon cas trouver l'amour
ou pas encore oui elle s'appelle
Sandrine les deux lourde elle nous suit
là ce soir je l'embrasse Sandrine alors
pas dans le pré non ça c'était
indirectement
pour faire vivre après l'émission mes
collègues agriculteurs qui rencontrent
aussi des difficultés qu'on parle pas
forcément puisqu'en fait quand on a des
difficultés et souvent on préfère se
taire parce que du coup c'est en fait
notre fierté notre métier c'est c'est
l'amour nos champs nos animaux et du
coup bah on n'est pas toujours bien
compris et du coup bah il y a la
récompense est pas forcément là alors
donc ce marché là sur toute la France
c'est une façon de nous rencontrer on
est tous des passionnés et puis aussi de
se soutenir le monde rural en général
soyez combien d'heures par jour tous les
deux
balancement moi c'est une période calme
donc je vais faire mes 8h30
je peux faire mes 8 10 heures mais
péniblement puisqu'en fait je reviens de
sous de santé très grave et en fait par
rapport au covid quand vous devez
hospitaliser j'étais hospitalisé on m'a
dit vous restez j'avais pas de solution
pour mes animaux je lui dis bon
débranche tout je me barre
vous êtes partis de l'hôpital vous êtes
tous Je pars vous me garderez pas j'ai
pas de solution pour me s'occuper de mes
vaches je rentre chez moi
parce que derrière ça on vous accuse
vous savez les animaux on s'occupe aussi
bien des naissances mais des fois on a
des moments très tristes on nous juge
là-dessus et donc on dit bah c'est un
mauvais éleveur ceci cela
et après moi j'ai choisi les animaux en
liberté dans les champs plutôt qu'en
bâtiment c'est un choix parce que du
coup c'est beaucoup plus de travail
c'est plus de surveillance et en
bâtiment bah c'est d'autres
problématiques et on est tous
agriculteurs on est tous des
complémentaires on vous offre notre
passion notre métier chacun à notre
façon et donc là plus que jamais on a
besoin d'unité mais lui c'est aussi
l'unité du pays parce que à l'heure
actuelle manger français c'est aider les
paysans français vous arrivez à à
dégager combien par mois au bout ça fait
zéro pas zéro travail pour rien ben ça
paye la nourriture de mes deux pas tout
là qui viennent d'arriver là parce que
le loup est arrivé en Normandie il est
passé donc le loup est passé
[Rires]
dans la ferme
voilà j'ai eu un souci à un moment donné
au mois de novembre ou parce que la
ferme est la maison souvent tout est lié
donc en fait on revient avec nos
difficultés à la maison et ben en fait
je me suis fait couper le courant et là
j'ai j'ai fait un j'étais complètement
je sais plus quoi faire et ça m'a c'est
ma compagne qui venait d'arriver dans ma
vie qui a fait des tout ce qu'elle
pouvait pour me remettre tout le courant
au mois de novembre mais c'était
extrêmement compliqué j'avais pas de
soutien autour de moi puisque bah
en étant agriculteur sur un bel espace
et bien on peut gêner des projets des
gens qui sont plus nombreux autour de
nous donc en fait c'est très difficile
d'avoir un soutien d'un maire d'avoir le
soutien de ses conseillers ou d'avoir le
soutien tout simplement de gens qui
veulent autre chose que de l'argent si
jamais on disparaît parce que si on
disparaît bah c'est des champs qui on va
pouvoir faire des maisons c'est à
l'heure actuelle c'est 50000 euros les
1000 mètres carrés et donc nous on va
gagner pas grand chose à l'hectare il
faut préciser que faut pas oublier que
trois quarts du territoire français
c'est qui qui s'en occupe
exactement si on continue comme ça c'est
la mort des agriculteurs n'ont pas
longtemps
déjà les enfants veulent pas prendre
donc il y a beaucoup de chefs de culture
comme moi tant mieux moi je suis un
passionné j'ai de la chance mais bon
mais
bon j'ai mon fils qui veut faire pareil
très bien on arrive à transmettre
mais si vous voyez pas les contraintes
quand même c'est énorme administratif
on a dit casquette pour ce métier là
pour des courses pour avoir 0 c'est ça
c'est incroyable là depuis une année on
s'était dit tiens les prix remonte ça va
faire plaisir les betteraves tout là on
nous met le coup de mature on va faire
on va plus faire de betteraves les
charges n'en parlons pas je vous parle
pas des charges les intrants tout ce qui
est engrais gasoil fioul etc ça explose
le matériel alors là c'est bon vous avez
vu plein de tracteurs
les journalistes c'est beau mais ça
appartient à la banque quand on a fait
de les payer il est usé il faut le
changer faut recommencer et un tracteur
comme ça comme je suis venu
que je suis venu ça vaut 250000 euros
250 millions c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
plusieurs tracteurs on a même plus les
moyens d'en acheter une donc la note
celle de mon patron elle a 10 ans on va
l'emmener jusqu'au bout parce que j'ai
de la chance c'est que je touche un peu
en mécanique on a des bons
concessionnaires donc on arrive à mais
bon c'est pas durable c'est pas durable
alors vive avec des subventions c'est
bien là le ministre j'ai entendu que le
ministre a dit oui pour les betteraves
c'est pas grave on va on va faire ce
qu'il faut pour vous analyser la perte
de betterave on veut pas vivre la
perfusion nous on veut vivre du travail
moi là je suis en colère va vraiment
colère c'est qu'il y a pas de ministre
d'agriculture qui est venu il y a pas
Macron a vu quelques élus de Paris qui
était très sympathique d'ailleurs et de
Paris quelques élus de Paris
mais il devait chercher les rats dans la
manifeste non non mais alors ceci dit je
retiens merci les Parisiens parce que on
les a vraiment emmerdés à travers ses
paris ils ont été super sympas des
photos vous êtes besoin applaudis moi je
on peut les applaudir parce que
franchement
[Applaudissements]
je te remercie aussi les syndicats parce
que sans eux c'est tout une organisation
il y a à peu près 500 tracteurs on vient
de tous les quatre points autour et que
ça va bouger vite pour vous alors
franchement je voulais mon fond de
penser vous y croyez pas du tout
pas du tout non elle a besoin de déjà
d'être à l'écoute on n'a pas de
perspective voilà on a pas de
perspective on a voilà du coup souvent
les gens qui ont des fermes essayent de
vendre un peu de Terra bâtir pour des
fois combler les problématiques de
trésorerie mais si vous avez pas de
terrain bâtir avant et ben vos problèmes
de trésorerie bah c'est compliqué moi ce
qui m'est arrivé c'est que en 2020
en 2019 bah en fait
situation était déjà pas évidente le
banquier me demande de mettre mes
économies pour que il me donne sa
confiance je lui donne mes économies et
derrière ça et il m'a il a essayé de me
mettre en l'air et donc ça voilà mais
c'est ce qui arrive à tout le monde donc
là ce qu'on a besoin c'est il faut
prendre en compte que tous les jours il
y a deux agriculteurs sur un suicide et
en fait on est là aussi pour ça parce
que le comment Patrick Morin marcheur de
l'espoir et l'action elle est pour que
vous sensibilisez que ces villas qui
sont là pour vous et sont utiles et que
ces gens là quand tout leur travail
toute leur passion ça fait que vous
manquerez pas de nourriture parce que là
vous manquez déjà un peu d'électricité
quand même c'est les prix ont flambés et
si jamais les prix de l'alimentation
flambe c'est pas fini ça fera comment il
y a des gens qui mangeront pas il a
raison de dire ça deux agriculteurs par
jour depuis quelques années en 2010 on
était plus de 520 000 agriculteurs en
2020 22 on est 415000 donc faire 100000
en un an l'équivalent d'un département
en disant bon maintenant il y a une
nouvelle loi qui est sorti depuis le 1er
janvier on a plus le droit d'artifiser
les terrains agricoles bon certes ok
c'est déjà un progrès mais purée mais
faut que ça bouge non mais c'est pas ça
c'est que vos enfants tous vont manger
je veux pas critiquer
c'est que je veux pas critiquer ce qui
vient de l'extérieur mais nous en France
on est depuis 20 ans élu la meilleure
agriculture du monde la plus durable la
plus propre et on veut encore être
encore plus propre de ses propres il y a
un moment on est en train de tuer en
train de te suicider on peut pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde c'est pas
possible j'ai discuté tout à l'heure
avec Laurent il est bio nous sur
l'exploitation on a 5% de bio céréales
et le reste en conventionnel comme je
lui ai dit on a besoin des deux ah bien
sûr on a besoin du bio parce qu'il y a
de la demande et pour ceux qui en
veulent et on a besoin du conventionnel
puisque des gens on a déjà du mal à
nourrir la planète